hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zeiten nur ein
videospiel schiller gesagt wir sollten
einfach mal ein paar unangenehme fragen
stellen und ich weiß dass das vom
maskottchen mit wiska basar und case und
grafik gemacht haben deswegen hier
kurzer ausschnitt aus deren videos alles
klar da eigentlich ausschnitt ist das
video geht jeden moment los ich wollte
nur ganz kurz noch mal schnell das
gewinnspiel auflösen was ich vor ein
paar tagen ja veranstaltet habe da
konnte die entweder in kisten und ein
buch mit zehn unterschrieben ins sichern
gewinnen und gewonnen haben die youtube
user namens uhr mo saurier und captain
draxler m ich habe euch beiden eine
youtube nachricht geschrieben dadurch
rein geschrieben wie ihr mir eure
adresse mitteilen sollte also ihr beiden
checkt auf jeden fall eure youtube
posteingängen und jetzt geht's ab mit
dem video watch this question was war
die wichtigste erfahrung die du je mit
insekten gemacht hast müsst will's nicht
hasse insekten nicht ich mag sie nicht
wenn sich über mir sind es ist genauso
wie mit fischen nicht mag fischer
eigentlich aber wenn nicht auch und die
see unterwegs als ihm dabei dann habe
ich beim tauchen kilogramm fisch gesehen
haben muss jetzt nicht sein dass du da
bist auf insekten bezogen war es die
erfahrung dass ich einmal in meinem bett
lag und die kennt das ja vielleicht wenn
ihr gerade soweit am einschlafen seit
dass ihr keinen bock habt wegen gegen
jucken am ohr oder irgendwas nochmal ihr
euch irgendwie in irgendeiner form zu
bewegen und bei mir als halt irgendwie
so am die jungs beziehungsweise so halb
im ohr da drin hat mich irgendwie
gejuckt und ich dachte mir scheißegal
wenn auf einmal irgendwas so in das ohr
ein gekrabbelt und nein es ist jetzt
nicht so eine art mäßige geschichte dass
das irgendwie mit einem paar aus
operiert werden musste sondern es war
einfach so ich hab dann eingegriffen
schnell und hab dann irgendwie so ganz
viele spinnen beide und so eine kleine
insekten artige keine ahnung was war da
drin
sich relative möglich an hat mich in dem
moment aber ehrlich gesagt nicht gewollt
also ich hab da rein gefasst aber so
rausgenommen und das mir so einen scheiß
egal fenster einfach weiter wer sind die
zwei mädchen auf der startseite von luca
job bis jetzt nicht wirklich nur
unangenehme frage aber die kommt
wirklich sehr häufig diese frage also in
dem bundesstaat von de gibt es halt ein
banner oben der sieht so aus und das
sind halt zwei mädchen rechts drauf das
ist die feste freundin von max und eine
kumpel freundin von mir aus köln ja
würdest du mit max zusammenziehen ich
weiß das ist auch keine unangenehme
frage ist kommen gleich noch ein paar
krassere ich will das auch gar nicht
irgendwie so sexuell versiert machen
dieses video hier aber ja ich würde auf
jeden fall mit mag zusammenziehen also
wir haben dann selber schon noch drüber
nachgedacht über den gedanken in so eine
wg zu ziehen das hat allerdings mit sich
einander lieben oder so zu tun sondern
wir sind einfach gute kumpels aber ich
bin einfach ein mensch der lieber allein
in seiner wohnung lebt also ich lebe
unglaublich gerne in geselligkeit aber
ich finde so wenn ich zu hause bin
möchte ich auch alleine sein ich würde
mal gerne dahinter der videos sein danke
danke für deine frage wann isst du mal
eine lehrerin attraktiv ich würde es
euch wirklich sagen wenn es so wäre aber
ich fand noch nie irgendeine lehrerin an
einer schule sexuell anziehend ich lese
immer beim eingang von irgendwelchen
seiten die darin was posten von wegen
die autokrise lehrerin an da würde ich
voll werden zur schule gehen nur hier
diese lehrerin darüber wie heißt dieser
meiner schule fand ich wirklich keine
irgendwie ansatzweise gut aussehend
sorry falls es einer von euch sehen
sollte ihr habt trotzdem guten
unterricht gemacht
willst du oft ja ich lüge unglaublich
häufig weiß man denkt jetzt etwas sowohl
was das für ein schlechter mensch aber
es ist halt einfach diese lüge die ich
glaube ich 20 mal am tag von mir gebe
ist einfach ja ich bin unterwegs und
daher ich bin gleich da oder hey wir
treffen uns dann und dann nicht wenn
pünktlich sein glaube jeder meiner
freunde geschäftspartner manager jeder
kann irgendwie bezeugen dass wenn man
sich mit mir treffen will immer
eigentlich von 20 minuten später aus
gehen muss weil ich mache es so ich
selbst auch für mich ist das so ich sage
leuten lieber hey lasst uns um 14 uhr
treffen und dann komme ich um 14 uhr 15
reiz dass ich sage lasst uns um 15 uhr
treffen und ich komme pünktlich um 15
uhr weil dann schwinge ich mich dazu
alle sachen die ich bis 14 uhr machen
möchte irgendwie hinzukriegen kommen
dann vielleicht zu spät zum meeting
anstatt bis 15 uhr alles safe locker hin
zu kriegen und dann zum meeting zu gehen
weil dann wenn ich welche verschiedene
weine ich setze mich quasi selbst unter
solchem druck das ist irgendwie blöd
aber irgendwie kann ich nur noch mittel
heben wann hast du das letzte mal
geweint und warum ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht was das letzte mal war habe
ich glaube das war wegen dem streit weil
ich habe noch nie irgendwie wegen einer
schulnote geheult oder gegen was weiß
ich dass ich in dem spiel verloren haben
oder keine ahnung was war das sich als
unnötig an es gibt so viel mehr im leben
weswegen man weinen sollte deswegen so
traurig sein sollte als sondert wir dass
die irgendwelche schulnoten oder das
irgendwie ein handy kaputt geht oder
sowas deswegen also ich habe glaube ich
das letzte mal geweint einem streit weil
was anderen weil ich eigentlich nie
wurdest du als kind aufgeklärt und
siehst du deine kinder mal aufklären
wenn du welche hast also ich hab nie die
sozial sind mit meinen eltern führen
müssen von wegen jan luca setzt immer
instabil und darüber wie man kinder mal
da bin ich auch ehrlich gesagt ganz froh
drüber also
also ich hatte in der schule halt in
biologie hatten wir so noch als einer
halben auf aufklärung
wieso nicht ich werde hier im tv auf
einmal eigentlich habe ich in der schule
oder zum schwimmen gelernt und irgendwie
keine ahnung jetzt ist selbst auch nicht
so schwer das ganze zu verstehen aber um
auf die frage zurückzukommen also so
richtig aufgeklärt wurde ich jetzt nicht
und wenn ich kinder habe werde ich die
glaube ich also ich kann ich jetzt noch
nicht sagen also ich meine ich komme ja
auch so ganz gut zurecht deswegen weil
akademie beantworten ihr merkt schon
dass dieses video jetzt nicht in die
richtung von anderen youtube angeht von
wegen dass ich sage wie lange mein penis
ist und wie oft ich schon irgendwelche
mädchen irgendwie in meinem bett hatte
oder so viel verteilte deswegen aber ich
finde sowas geht so weit dass ins
internet zu stellen aber das ist ja
jedem selbst überlassen und wenn sich
leute damit schmücken dann sonst gerne
machen aber ich werde nicht nach und ich
hab mir jetzt einfach andere arten von
unangenehmen fragen rausgesucht was ist
deine schlimmste sucht das habe ich
vorhin schon teilweise erwähnt und zwar
habe ich wirklich diese sucht immer was
machen zu müssen wenn man das ganze
überhaupt sucht nennen kann ich hasse es
einfach mit kollegen einfach um zu
chillen und einfach nur chillen ich
hoffe dass ich muss immer irgendwie was
machen sei es ihnen die playstation
spiele nebenbei oder irgendwo hingehen
oder irgendwie laufen sport machen
arbeiten ich weiß dass ich jetzt total
bescheuert an und viele sagen jetzt
wahrscheinlich wo ich wünschte ich hätte
so eine sucht in anführungszeichen aber
es ist für mich wirklich oft so dass
sich nicht richtig schlafen kann im bett
liegen wären denkt okay irgend habe ich
heute nicht viel geschafft ich war es
ist komisch aber es ist für mich schwer
dagegen gesund bin himmel nicht und
denken dann so ok ich muss jetzt noch
irgendwas machen sei es irgendwie noch
mal kurz nach oben gehen was essen oder
hier noch was machen oder keine ahnung
was haltet ihr euch gerne die klamotten
und dazu hat sie ein bild an gefangen wo
man wie das max nicht teilweise die
gleichen klamotten tragen dass das liegt
nicht an max sondern es liegt
tatsächlich nur in mir ich bin einfach
ein mensch ich kann nicht planen was
mein gepäck für eine reise angeht ok max
ist eigentlich auch nicht so ein mensch
magst du dich in der royals gefahren und
das primäre ziel der reise war wild
filmmaker kamera und ladekabel vergessen
ja und es ist jetzt auch nicht so dass
man sie nicht uns rund um die uhr
klamotten teilen sondern es war halt
wirklich auf dem einen bild so in wales
ich habe halt keinen richtigen die
mittel des war mega kalt und ich dachte
es sei noch sommer deswegen hat er mir
dann seinen pulli halter einfach gelegen
bei der anderen sache war es wegen dem
video ich installer wieder nachgestellt
hat und ich brauchte einen schwarzen
pullover und deswegen haben uns ein
dunkin geteilt aber ich meine ich lade
auch so manchmal kumpels von mir wenn
ihr halt einfach bei mir gefällt haben
nach einer feier oder socken oder sogar
dann alles super hier das hat nichts mit
schwulsein zu tun oder irgendwie so das
wird nur was mit anziehen und kümmern
ist der schon mal während des aufnehmens
etwas peinliches passiert und du
musstest rausschneiden ich habe vor
einem halben jahr mal in einem video
richtig fett gefurzt und das war jetzt
nicht so wie hier das wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie vor zu würde dass ich sagen
würde okay dann merkt man einfach wo ich
gerade den cut gemacht hat und nehmen es
dann wieder von vorne auf sondern das
war halt in der gaming aufnahme und das
ist halt immer noch was anderes weil ja
fragen sich natürlich schon die leute ok
warum wo das ist raus geschnitten das
ist ja so durchlaufen das video
eigentlich wieso setzen card an der
stelle da sieht man ja gar nicht der
übergang war das war bei sonderfolge
turbo diesmal und ich habe gerade seine
geilen job hingelegt und wollte dann
kommentieren aber hab irgendwie halten
bevor und es war laut und ich hab dann
gedacht ok es waren der tonspur zu sehen
muss ich halt rauscht ein und konnte
deswegen in heißen samba nicht mit rein
nehmen
ja das war es was war deine schlechteste
note bzw punktzahl während der schulzeit
ich hab mal auf den zeugnissen 4 - in
physik bekommen weil ich bei einer
zusammenfassung bei der man nach und
nach nach vorne gehen musste und etwas
zusammenfassen sollte habe ich gesagt
dass sich die sonne um die erde dreht
also ich habe dazu rechnet 4 -
gesprochen warst du schon mal so richtig
betrogen dass du dich an nichts mehr
erinnert hast ich bin eigentlich echt
ein mensch der nicht viel alkohol trinkt
also ich hätte jetzt nicht jeden abend
in der bar oder jedes wochenende im klub
und gibt mir übel ist die kante und kann
mich an nichts mehr erinnern macht das
eigentlich eher genuss weise weil es
gibt schon irgendwie ein paar coole
cocktails die ich auf jeden fall mega
feier oder irgendwelche longdrink
kombinationen aber dass ich mal mich
mega abgeschossen habe das war hat sich
gerade mein abi geschafft hat
er hat eine so gefahren und haben
deshalb nicht auf genuss alkohol
getrunken sondern einfach zur feier
zelebration zwecken und bei seiner abi
fahrt feuer fängt man nicht an irgendwie
abends um acht uhr zu trinken sondern
wir haben dann irgendwie mittags um
zwölf angefangen und es war mega
sonnenschein und dass wir noch beim
fahrrad irgendwo hingefahren dann wenn
man trinkt plus sonnenschein das ist
eine ganz blöde kommen wie jedenfalls
würde ich von dieser feier dann
irgendwann ein nachmittag von meiner
mutter abgeholt weil ich halt echt
fertig war und war total ko und habe mir
den fuß verstaucht oder sowas in der
richtung und das dass das war
tatsächlich nicht so cool
das war meine meine schlimmste erfahrung
bisher hast du schon mal bei einer
polizeikontrolle betrunken kann ich ganz
einfach beantworten und zwar nein weil
ich noch nie eine polizeikontrolle hat
die können mich wirklich gern
kontrollieren also ich bin jetzt kein
mensch der irgendwie nach einer party
nach drei wodka sagte komm ich bringe
jetzt nach hause ich kann noch fahren
oder so ich finde es einfach und
verantwortungsvoll ich halt wieder die
straßenverkehrsordnung im fahrzeugschein
führerschein dabei also aber bisher ist
mir noch nicht passiert hattest du
letztens einen knutschfleck diesen
kommentar habe ich so oft bekommen da
war hier ein video von mir wo ich so
eine hautirritationen hier haben kinder
hat und alle meinten so das ist krupps
aktueller freund denn eines war ein
knutschfleck ich versichere euch dass
jetzt hier in diesem video ich hatte
noch nie irgend einem video familien
knutschfleck ich habe das oft so dass
ich irgendwie zu hause bin und dusche
und dann direkt ein video danach
aufnehme dann ist meine heutigen wie
hier vorne machen wir so ein bisschen
trocken
sie hat ein bisschen an gerötet und es
ist kein krieg sondern dass es nicht
weil das kann was es ist doch nicht weg
das wäre nicht ich sehe das auch im
schnitt nicht das sehen halte ich nur
leute die sich wirklich genau darauf
spezialisiert und genau darauf achten ob
das was sein könnte aber es war kein ko
spiele hasst du schon mal einen jungen
geküsst und wenn ja wohin
lügen wenn ich die frage negativ
beantworten würde ja ich habe schon mal
geküsst aber jetzt hat noch nie so
richtig leidenschaftlich auf den mund
und mit liebe mit dabei und keine ahnung
dann hat eigentlich nur bei
irgendwelchen trinkspielen oder wenn man
eine wette verloren hat oder keine
ahnung was und dann halt auch nur auf
die wange
andere wäre total auf wort also ich habe
schon mal ein junger geküsst aber jetzt
nicht so von wegen okay ich wollte das
jetzt und das ding von meiner seite aus
und so bleibst du deine eigenen videos
ja schon manchmal also ich meine ich
finde es auch überhaupt nicht
verwerflich viele sagen ja auch immer so
war die eine da die hudbay instagram
ihre eigenen bilder gelegt ich weiß
nicht was daran so schlimm sein soll
weil ich mein mann lebens ja nur hoch
wenn es einen selber gefällt und genauso
ist ja auch bei youtube videos und wenn
man es nicht reichen würde eins ist ja
das ist einem selber irgendwie nicht so
ganz gefällt verschiedenen also ich mach
das jetzt nicht so dass ich meine ganzen
videos und instagram bilder durchgehen
und das selber leid sondern es ist halt
einfach häufig so wenn ich gerade ein
video hochgeladen habe und ich praxis
der playlist rein das ist dann einfach
auch maike weil dadurch sehen es die
leute halt auch noch mal in ihrem
newsfeed aber diese debatte warum so
schlimm ist seine eigenen sachen zu
leiten verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
so ganz weil nennt mir einen plausiblen
grund warum nicht schlimm sein soll das
ist deshalb nichts damit zu tun dass man
dann irgendwie opfer ist oder so sondern
es hat einfach nur in einem der eigene
content gefällt und sonst versteht ihr
was ich meine
das was hier mit dem video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen weil sie das getan hat last auf
jeden fall mal lag da wie schon zu
beginn des videos gesagt wird es nicht
so viele fragen angenommen die so so
unangenehm und peinlich sinn weil ich
mich ja auch nicht komplett bloßstellen
will hier im internet deswegen habe ich
einfach solche fragen ich hoffe das war
eine ganz gute kommen hier findet hier
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
ihr könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren und
ihr findet hier ein anderes video
eingeblendet was sie da verlinken wer
weiß noch nicht genau an dem wir uns
einander wieder irgendwie wieder